DAY, SHE WAS TAKING A VICTORY
LAP IN SOME WAYS.
>> WE WILL COVER THE LATEST IN
THE MOMENT BUT JOINING US NOW
WITH MORE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
EXECUTIVE ACTION IS AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVE UNION CHAIR MATCH
LAP, FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN, THE
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT, GERALDO
RIVERO IN A STUDIO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
LET'S START WITH THIS
DECLASSIFICATION.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST.
IS THIS THE MOMENT THAT SPYGATE
COCONSPIRATORS HAVE BEEN
DREADING FOREVER?
>> IT SURE IS COME UP MONDAY
NIGHT ON THIS SHOW I PREDICTED
WE WERE DAYS FROM ACTION AND
WEEKS FROM EVIDENCE.
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT IS THAT
IT SHOWS THAT COMEY, BRENNAN ARE
ALL IN JEOPARDY.
IF THIS WAS A QUESTION OF
MISCONDUCT THE PRESIDENT
WOULDN'T HAVE GIVEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S GIVING
AUTHORITY TO COMPEL THE
PRODUCTION OF EVIDENCE FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THE CIA,
THE NSA AND THAT IS WHERE I
BELIEVE THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
WAS WITHHELD FROM THE COURTS
WHERE GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AS
SAYING WE WERE INCLUDING, THAT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
THAT WAS WITHHELD.
YOU MENTION THE GANG OF EIGHT
BRIEFINGS AND WHAT IS SO
IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT IS THAT
THEY INCLUDE STATEMENTS OF
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD HAVE SHOWN
THAT CARTER PAGE AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS WERE NOT A BASIS TO
CONTINUE THIS INVESTIGATION AND
THAT IS NOT GOING TO LINE UP
WITH WHAT WAS PRESENTED TO THE
FISA COURT.
THAT DESPERATE DISPLAY WILL
REALLY SHOW WHERE THE CORRUPTION
OCCURRED AND THEY SHOULD BE VERY
WORRIED.
>> Dan: I WILL GO TO YOU NEXT.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THEY WERE IN A WORLD OF TROUBLE.
HE BRINGS UP A GREAT POINT, WHEN
BILL BARR WAS UP ON THE HILL AND
THE TESTIMONY HE DIDN'T JUST SAY
THE FBI, HE WAS VERY CLEAR IT
WAS POSSIBLE MALFEASANCE WITH
THE COMMUNITY AND SHE WAS VERY
SPECIFIC.
NOT JUST THE FBI.
THIS MAY BE BIGGER THAN JUST FBI
SPYING AND I THINK THEIR DAYS
ARE NUMBERED.
>> I THINK THAT FIRST OF ALL TO
WATCH THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
OF THE PRESIDENT GOING AT EACH
OTHER LIKE JUNIOR HIGH STUDENTS
IS VERY DISHEARTENING.
THIS IS REALLY NOT GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY.
HE PERSONAL SNIPING.
IN THE SPEAKER'S CASE HOWEVER,
WHAT IS REVEALED BY HER USE OF
THE TERMS COVER-UP AND SO FORTH
LEADING UP TO OUR MEETING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE, THE AGENDA OF
THE SPEAKER HAS BEEN EXACTLY IN
SYNC WITH THE MOST RADICAL
MEMBERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS.
SHE IS THINKING IMPEACHMENT.
SHE WANTS TO PROVE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE WITH ALL HER MIGHT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS, WHEN THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE REVEALED WHAT IT
WILL SHOW IS AN OBSTRUCTION OF
INJUSTICE.
THE PRESIDENTS FRUSTRATION, HAS
FLAILING OUT OF THE DEMOCRATS IS
BECAUSE HE COMMITTED NO
COLLUSION.
THERE IS NO UNDERLYING CRIME.
IT IS NOT WATERGATE AND PEOPLE
USING THAT PARALLEL AN ANALOGY
INCLUDING OUR OWN JOBS ARE WAY
OFF BASE BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION!
ITS OBSTRUCTION OF INJUSTICE.
THIS IS DANGEROUS, IT'S RECKLESS
RHETORIC FROM THE PRESIDENT OF A
SPEAKER AND THEY BETTER COOL IT
RIGHT NOW.
MAYBE THE WEEKEND WILL GIVE THEM
SOME TIME TO PONDER IT.
AS THIS EVIDENCE COMES OUT I
WANT TO KNOW AT WHAT POINT TO
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR NO TO A
REASONABLE CERTAINTY THAT THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION.
WHY DID HE TELL THE PRESIDENT
WHEN HE GOT TO THAT POINT THAT
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
WAS HE TRYING TO ENTRAP THE
PRESIDENT IN A PERJURY TRAP?
>> I DON'T BLAME THE PRESIDENT
AT ALL FOR BEING UPSET.
YOU ARE ACCUSING HIM FOR BEING A
COVER-UP AND A CRIME.
CAN I JUST ASK YOU, YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND THE LEGISLATIVE ARENA FOR
A LOT LONGER THAN I HAVE, WHAT
IS THE LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE OF
ALL OF THIS?
CONGRESS IS NOT THE FBI.
THEIR OVERSIGHT AND THEIR
ABILITIES, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG ARE TO LEGISLATE.
>> THAT YOU HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH IS IN THE
POWER AND THEIR ABILITY TO FUND
THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE A LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT
BUT WHAT THEY DO NOT HAVE A
RIGHT TO DO IS TO HAVE THEIR OWN
PROSECUTORIAL INVESTIGATION
WHICH IS WHY THE PROPER THING
FOR BILL BARR WHO BY THE WAY,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS BEEN
UNDERGOING AN INVESTIGATION FOR
QUITE SOME TIME NOW SO THE FACT
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOW
TAKING THIS EXTRAORDINARY STEP
WHICH WE BEEN WAITING FOR FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS.
IT PROBABLY MEANS THIS IS WELL
ENOUGH ALONG WHERE THEY HAVE A
GRASP OF WHAT THEY WANT TO
DECLASSIFY, WHAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE PUBLIC AND HERE IS THE KEY,
TWO KEY THINGS, NUMBER ONE, THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE THE WIND OUT OF
THE SAILS OF IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S NO LONGER ABOUT ALL THE
COVERAGE OF POTENTIAL WRONGDOING
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP WHICH HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE WRONG, IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE ABOUT THE OBAMA
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT DID THEY KNOW, WHAT DID
THEY KNOW WHAT?
WHAT DIDN'T THEY STOP?
WHY DID THEY USE THEIR POWERS IN
AN UNAUTHORIZED WAY TO GO AFTER
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THIS PUTS THE ISSUE ON THE OTHER
FOOT AS HE WAS SAYING, IT'S NOT
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRAVIS
WRONGDOING, IT'S ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THOSE OBAMA
YEARS AND I THINK THIS IS
NOTHING BUT POSITIVE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GET
TO THE TRUTH.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN IF YOU ARE
UP THERE AND LIVING WITH US
EVERY DAY.
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY THAT WHEN
BILL BARR TALKS ABOUT THIS BEING
BIGGER THAN THE FBI, IF YOU
WATCH THIS TESTIMONY SHE SEEMS
VERY CONFUSED THAT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION IN THE FBI MAY HAVE
BEEN WITH THE CIA AS WELL.
IT SEEMS APPARENT BASED ON
BRENNAN'S BRIEFINGS THAT THE
SOURCES WERE THE SAME.
IS IT POSSIBLE THERE WERE
PARALLELS AS A PATH?
>> OF THE STRONGEST EVIDENCE
THOSE PARALLEL PATHS EXISTED IS
THAT YOU HAVE BRENNAN AND COMEY
PUTTING FINGERS AT ONE ANOTHER
ABOUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
DOSSIER FUNDED BY DEMOCRATS,
COOKED UP BY LIARS AND THEN
COMINGLED WITH RUSSIAN
INFORMATION WASN'T REALLY A
DRIVING FORCE OF THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK AS WE GET CLOSER TO THE
TARGET YOU WILL SEE MORE OF A
CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD START TO
START AMONG THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WERE SO READY TO DERAIL THE
PRESIDENCY THAT THEY TOOK LEGAL
ACTION THAT HAD NO DEFENSE
ATTORNEY.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
THE DISCOURSE HERE, IT'S REALLY
STRANGE WITH HER SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE QUESTION THE PRESIDENT'S
MENTAL STATE, BUT I SEE IS THE
QUESTION OF IMPEACHMENT IS
TORTURING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AT THE PRESIDENT NEEDS AN
INTERVENTION I THINK
NANCY PELOSI AND THE REST OF HER
CAUCUS NEED TO GO ON DR. PHIL
AND TALK ABOUT THEIR FEELINGS
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE ABOVE
THAT.
HE DOESN'T NEED THAT.
HE IS WINNING NOW.
LET BILL BARR DO HIS JOB.
THEY WILL BE UNCOVERED AND WE
WILL SEE WHO DID WHAT.
>> HE WAS ABLE TO GET
16,000,000,002 ARE FARMERS,
NEGOTIATE THROUGH A GRIDLOCK ON
A RESPONSE AND HE WAS ABLE TO
CENTRALIZE THIS INVESTIGATION ON
THE GREATEST POLITICAL SCANDAL
AND HISTORY, THAT IS A GOOD DAY
FOR SOMEONE WHO NEEDS AN
INTERVENTION.
>> Dan: I HAVE TO RUN BUT IT'S
FUNNY WHEN MUELLER PUMPS THE
FOOTBALL THEN DEMOCRATS
COMPLAIN.